this week in tech amazon took the
fastest growing social media app of all
time
and migrated it to its new serverless
platform putting it in the highly
undesirable position
of requiring a reverse cloud migration
most companies migrate from
on-prem to the cloud but this
unfortunate app needs to do the exact
opposite because nobody in town wants to
touch it whether you agree with the
politics of that or not
one thing is undeniable tech monopolies
have a lot of power over your business
so don't walk around here thinking you
have free will because you don't i can
crush you anytime
i want and a lot of influence over the
content we consume
as end users that being said if you're
some kind of weirdo who doesn't trust
the cloud
this video is for you we'll take a
raspberry pi and turn it into a physical
server
that can host a web application on the
internet or in other words you'll build
your own mini
amazon web services from scratch along
the way you'll learn some cool things
about linux networking nginx node.js
and why if you have a large scale app
and get kicked off of aws
you're pretty much screwed to follow
along the first thing you'll need is a
raspberry pi
i'm using the model 4 which has a quad
core processor
and 8 gigabytes of ram and ironically i
bought it as a kit from amazon for about
120 bucks
it comes with a power supply all the
cords you need as well as a memory card
with linux pre-installed
the linux flavor is designed
specifically for raspberry pi
it's called noobs and feels pretty
similar to ubuntu
now i'm not going to go through the
physical hardware setup here which is
really just a matter of plugging in
different size cords to different sized
holes i'll be starting from the noob's
operating system
with the only extra piece of software
installed being vs code
now our goal here is to create a node.js
web application
that can serve html from the raspberry
pi to the rest of the internet
throughout the world
but before we do that let's talk about
some of the challenges and how it
compares to hosting a website on the
cloud
the first issue is scale we're working
with a fixed amount of computing power
it's a great value and only a fraction
of the price for an equal amount of
computing power on aws
when averaged out for three years the
issue is that our app can only grow so
much
if we need to grow or scale up we need
to buy more raspberry pi's
and figure out how to distribute the
load across them and we'd likely want to
do that
in different parts of the world to make
our infrastructure closer to the end
user
and also to provide fault tolerance just
in case some kind of natural disaster
destroys a raspberry pi like a volcano
or peaceful protesters
in addition we also need to think about
security because we're dealing with a
highly controversial app here
as soon as we go back online every coder
in the world is going to try to hack it
to pieces
in order to save humanity from the
buffalo guy another major drawback of
this on-prem approach
is that it takes a lot of manual
configuration like we need to plug in
cables work with power companies to
supply electricity internet service
providers to provide ip addresses
and the list goes on on the other hand
with aws we can do everything from a
computer screen it's all fully managed
and much easier to work with but once
you're kicked off you really only have
two options
build your own data centers or file an
anti-trust lawsuit
both of which are terrible options but
let's go with the first one from here
we're going to build a node.js app
directly in the raspberry pi
it's a classic web page that tells you
how many times the page has been viewed
node is already installed so we can open
up an empty directory
then run npm init y to create a new npm
project
from there we can install express.js to
help us build a web app
i am creating a javascript file called
server.js for our main source code
then instead of a database i'm just
adding a text file to the project
which we can read and write to to get
the current count of people who have
viewed the web page
and the javascript file will import read
file sync and write file sync from
node.js
and then create a new express app the
express app will listen
on localhost 5000. from there we just
need an endpoint to the root url
that will update the view count and then
send back the raw html to the browser
in express we can create an http
endpoint by calling
app get followed by the url which in
this case will just be the root url
we can get the current view count by
calling read file sync which we'll set
to a variable
coming from a text file it's a string so
we'll parse it into an integer then add
one to it
then we'll simply write that value back
to the same file the final step is to
send a response from the endpoint
which is just a raw html string but
we'll interpolate the view count into it
so the user can see that in the ui
that's all it takes to build a web app
now we can run it by calling
nodeserver.js from the command line
now at this point you should be able to
open localhost 5000 on the raspberry pi
browser and see your web app displayed
there at this point we have a working
web app
but we're building a sirius app here and
that means we're going to deploy it with
nginx
once we add multiple raspberry pi's to
our data center we'll be able to use
nginx to balance the load across them
nginx is not installed on raspberry pi
by default
so we need to open up the terminal and
first run sudo
apt update to get the latest information
from the package manager then we can run
sudo apt
install nginx this adds nginx to the etc
directory which we can run with sudo
followed by the start command
this runs a default web page on the
raspberry pi which we can access on its
internal ip address
you can find the ip address by running
hostname flag capital i
then paste that value into the browser
it should say welcome to nginx but what
we actually want to do here
is proxy it to our nodejs application
running on localhost 5000.
we can modify the default config in the
etc
nginx sites available directory i've
removed all the comments leaving only
the default config
the only modification that we need to
make here is to add proxy pass to
localhost 5000
and that basically tells any traffic
going to the root url to use the nodejs
app
save the file then apply the changes by
running sudo nginx restart
now that we have our app running the way
we want it on the raspberry pi
we need to make it available to the
internet the internal ip address can be
used on your own local network
but in order to make the website
available to the outside world on the
internet
we need an external ip address an
external ip address is provided by your
internet service provider
like comcast verizon at t or whatever
for most people they provide a dynamic
ip address that can change on a regular
basis
but it's not a great thing if you're
trying to host a website because once
the ip changes
then that means your website is no
longer available on the internet
that means if we want to serve our web
app from a raspberry pi we have two
options
we could call up the isp and ask them
for a static ip address
these guys don't exactly have a great
reputation for customer service
but getting a static ip from the
provider is probably the best option
luckily there is an alternative there
are a few services out there that can
monitor your dynamic ip
and update it on the dns for a domain
when it changes
in other words it makes your dynamic ip
behave like a static ip i'm going to be
using noip.com
because it has a free tier and it worked
for me just fine when you sign up
you pick a free domain name and it will
automatically detect your external ip
as the a record in the dns but in order
for it to detect changes
on the raspberry pi we need to install
some software there
basically you just download a binary
execute it and then it will have you log
in with your username and password
to link the account to the raspberry pi
once that's done we effectively have a
static ip
but there's still one more step left to
get this thing working
if we try to navigate to the external ip
at this point we get a blank screen
by default your router will not allow
outside traffic to get into your network
it's like a giant fence with a bunch of
doors in it that are all currently
closed
these doors are called ports and our app
is currently being served on port 80.
that means we need to open up port 80
on our router to external traffic
through a process called
port forwarding the exact steps will
depend entirely on the router you use
but there is a website called
portforward.com that has a breakdown for
basically every router out there once
you connect to the router you should be
able to find port forwarding under the
advanced options
what you'll do is add a new forwarding
rule with starting and ending ports for
80
that connect your internal ip address to
any external ip address
and remember you can get your internal
ip address by running hostname
flag capital i from the command line
once you have that done
you should now be able to navigate to
your external ip address and the result
should be the node.js app that we built
earlier
congratulations you just built your own
amazon web services from scratch
but they may take our lives but they'll
never take
our freedom
[Music]
well maybe not exactly but you did host
your own website from a raspberry pi
that's not entirely dependent on a big
cloud monopoly
it's not going to scale very well yet
but at least it's a start i'm going to
go ahead and wrap things up there let me
know what you think in the comments
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one